as prices rise at the pump so do profits
for oil and gas companies
bp announcing a bumper first quarter
reigniting calls for a windfall tax to
help with the growing cost of living
crisis
but the prime minister is resisting
concerned that easing pain today could
cause problems tomorrow
if you put a a windfall tax on
on the energy companies
what that means is that you discourage
them from making the investments that we
want to see that will in the end keep
energy prices lower for everybody bp's
ceo unsurprisingly agrees the message
he's pushing it's not just investments
in renewable energy on the line these
are profits that are then rewarding our
shareholders who by the way are not some
faceless institutions but pretty much
anyone who has a pension or pays into a
pension in the uk is affected by that
it has been an extraordinary period for
bp
it lost 19 billion pounds after the war
in ukraine forced it to offload shares
in the russian state oil company rosneft
but because of high oil and gas prices
underlying profits soared to 4.9 billion
pounds in the first quarter of this year
more than double the year before
the companies also promised to invest 18
billion pounds in green and fossil fuel
energy in the uk by the end of the
decade this company and others like it
often point out that it was just a few
years ago they were suffering record
losses because of the pandemic and that
it's not reasonable to face extra
taxation every time they do well but
campaigners and critics say that the
fossil fuel industry simply cannot be
trusted to do the right thing of its own
accord whether that's investing in clean
green energy or helping ease the
financial pressures on ordinary people
that's why labour wants to take the
money now rather than hope for it down
the line
a windfall tax only hits those profits
that the oil and gas companies didn't
expect to make and therefore it doesn't
affect their other investments it's a
practical way to help millions of people
with their energy bills it's labor's
proposal the government has got no
answer corporate freedom versus the
acute needs of millions being pushed
towards fuel poverty
for the government an uncomfortable
balancing act and possibly a moment of
political peril
hannah thomas peter sky news in central
london